Ariel winter confirmed she single as she
continues to flaunt her seriously sexy
bikini body I think it's the right
choice for me when you're in an awesome
relationship and you're both really
supportive it's awesome that was Ariel
winter in October 2015
opening up to ET about her then beau
Laurent Claude cadet but on Saturday the
18 year old actress not so subtly
confirmed she's now single by posting
this gift to Twitter it's a still shot
of Kim Kardashian from Keeping Up with
the Kardashians the quote says I'm like
dropping hints that I'm single and get
this she further clarified her
relationship status in the caption
writing when you're surprised that
people just haven't gotten it yet ET
reached out to Ariel's rep about the
supposed split earlier this month but we
were told she had no comment about the
speculation so yeah the Modern Family
star might be flying solo these days but
she has plenty of reasons to smile
Ariel recently graduated from high
school and she's got two million
Instagram followers to celebrate the
social media milestone she posted this
pic on Sunday showing off a whole lot of
booty in a tie-dye bikini she gushed in
the caption wow I can't believe it love
you guys so much
you